Now to wrap up, let's talk about how we might package our projects.
We've been talking about how we might approach the actual development tools.
Now, how do we get the project that we've created and deploy it to the target platform?
So it's important to note there's a variety of different packaging types you can use.
You can use Dev versus Release.
So if you want to have console commands access to you or any kind of development information,
as we spoke about in a previous slide, you can use a Dev Release for this to be able to just debug any information.
And if you want Release, then there'll be no access.
It's for the end consumer or the end user that you want to experience that.
You don't really want the debug information in there.
So we can get started by the Unreal Engine Android development.
And so we can run the setup Android back, which is found in our Epic Games engine folder.
We want to install Android Studio.
And then if using the 5.0 version of Unreal Engine, you want to install these extra versions.
So anything 5.1 on later will already come with some of this content.
So just double check which versions you're using and install the relevant APIs.
You can also enable developer mode on the device.
You want to check your Android version and typically tap in build number seven times.
We'll allow that here on the bottom left hand side that you can see.
And make sure don't sleep while charging is enabled and then also allow USB debugging.
When we're making a new project, we want to create a new blank project in Unreal Engine.
So you just want to load the Epic Games launcher, pick a project, but then pick a blank project
because this will be the cleanest version of a project that you can cook and package.
And we want to just make sure the mobile and minimal settings are applied.
So when you see the new project screen, you can just make sure you tick it's for mobile
and the minimal settings are applied there.
Then we can make a blank map.
And if we go to maps and modes in the project settings, so to find the project settings,
we go to edit at the top, go down to project settings and there'll be a maps and modes in the project setting.
And this new map that we've created, you can just assign that map as the editor startup map and also the game default map.
The game mode and instance can be set there as well.
If you want to update that or change that.
When we've created a new level, we want to create a couple of new blueprints.
So we want to create a new controller and a new game mode.
So for testing, you may be able to enable mouse click events.
So you can do that in the controller as we showed earlier in the course, enable touch events there, enable click events is also accessible.
When we've created the new controller in the game mode, we can then just assign those in the actual game instance class that we have.
So you'll see again, these changed icons here.
This is what we've got.
So we've got our custom controller.
We've got our hood class and we've got our palm class.
Next, we will make sure our project settings are set up correctly for Android.
So we'll go back into our project settings.
Again, you can find it edit at the top of your Unreal Engine browser and go to project settings.
Go to the platform section and find Android and you just want to make sure you configure your project for Android here.
And then optional, but you can show console on four finger tap, which is the tick box there just in case you want any debug information.
We can then create a new UMG widget by right clicking in your content browser,
going to user interface and adding a widget blueprint.
And you just when this box comes up, you can just click use a widget here.
That's fine.
And then we want to just create a basic window like this.
So you want the canvas panel at the bottom as your first property here.
And then you've got a background image.
We've also got a test button and some test text.
So we've just created a basic UMG like this with some kind of button that will be accessed within the blueprint.
So in the blueprint, we want to make sure we load up the custom controller that we assign to our game instance on event begin play of the controller.
We want to drag off event begin play.
And if you just type create widgets, then.
It'll add a create widget box and we just want to assign the UMG widget that we just created in the previous slide.
So when you assign that there, that will the text here will update to whatever you called your widgets.
So in this instance, we called it example widget.
And so you can see create example widget widget.
When you drag off owning player, drag off to the left and type self that will create a little self reference.
And it just makes sure it adds to itself.
And then on the return value, you can drag off here and type add to viewport.
And that will add your example UMG to the screen.
Then when if we want to test it, we can test on the mobile preview.
So on platforms, which is at the top of your viewport here, you can just go to mobile preview and then you can play a new editor window.
And that will allow you to test whether the button is then clickable.
To test deploying to the device, again, we can use this drop down here and we want to check that we've installed the SDK and Android Studio.
We want to make sure we ran the setup Android back at the top of the hands on section here.
And we want to make sure developer mode is unlocked on the device.
Compression between PC and HMI are different.
So just make sure you pay attention to that.
And then also it takes time to build and deploy.
So when you click and it's just compiling and doing its thing, don't worry, it can take time to do that.
You can run the Unreal Insights as we referenced previously if you want to test.
But you just need to make sure you install that first.
And so some packaging settings to use, you can choose whether you want the compressed cooked packages.
You want you want to exclude.
You can choose whether you want to exclude on any unnecessary content.
So maybe you only want to cook certain maps or have a list of some specific maps.
Do you want to make sure it's not for distribution?
Do you want to blueprint native eyes anything, which again is size versus speed as a trade off between performance?
And then do you want to do a full rebuild or do you just want to iterate through the build so that every time you package the game, it gets a little bit faster?
So here are a few options you may want to set for yourself inside your project settings.
And then lastly, talking about packaging, we can go to platforms at the top of the browser here.
You can go to Android and you can make sure that you have the Android ETC to set.
And for this instance, we probably want a development packaging build so we can test those debug settings.
We can do that four finger tap.
And this is essentially how we would go about packaging a project.
So you can click package.
Just know that that takes quite a while to go through.
But by the end of it, you should have a package deployed build on your Android device.
And you can then use it to debug any information you may want to see on the screen there.